[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à bruxelles pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo
cette semaine on va essayer de répondre
à cette question avec l'arrivée de
donald trump aux états unis qui veut la
dislocation de l'europe le break si dur
de theresa may en grande bretagne est ce
que l'europe peut éclater si on va
essayer de répondre à cette question
avec nos invités aujourd'hui richard
corbett
bonjour vous êtes eurodéputé britannique
membre du groupe des socialistes et
démocrates ici au parlement européen
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation à
côté de vos nathalie griesbeck bonjour
cette députée française membre du groupe
de l'alliance des démocrates et libéraux
pour l'europe ici au parlement européen
en france vous avez été élu sous les
couleurs du modem
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
fin jean quatremer que je ne présente
plus habituée d'europe hebdo il faudrait
qu'on pense à vous rémunérer un jour
c'est gratuit opus vous êtes
correspondant du journal libération à
bruxelles
alors je le disais trump break site
l'union européenne prise en tenaille on
regarde le sujet et ont réagi juste
après
[Musique]
le jour j donald trump devient
officiellement le 45e président des
états unis il ya bien eu quelques
sifflets mais bel et bien président des
états unis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dès sa première prise de parole publique
en tant que nouveau président élu
donald trump donne le ton des fonds à
compter de ce jour une nouvelle vision
va gouverner notre pays
à compter de ce jour ce sera l'amérique
d'abord l'amérique d'abord à maka fuck
america first ou le retour d'une
amérique isolationniste l'amérique mais
pas seulement
quelques jours plus tôt à londres cette
fois c'est un moment qui restera dans
l'histoire
sur ces images dans quelques secondes le
premier ministre britannique annonce une
rupture claire et nette avec l'union
européenne un brick si dur
ce que je propose ne peut pas signifier
une appartenance au marché unique qui
t'ont l'union européenne mais nous ne
quittons pas l'europe et c'est pour cela
que nous voulons un partenariat nouveau
et égale entre un royaume uni mondial
indépendant qui s'auto gouverne et nos
amis et alliés dans l'union européenne
pad d'adhésion partiel à l'union ni
d'adhésion associé à l'union ou quoi que
ce soit qui ne laisse à moitié dedans et
à moitié dehors divorcée quitter le
marché commun tout en sauvant les
meubles en négociant des accords
douaniers et commerciaux avantageux
c'est la stratégie dévoilée par teresa
may la négociation qui pourrait débuter
en mars s'annonce difficile
les européens sont sur leurs gardes
surtout que donald trump se dit prêt à
soutenir les britanniques en concluant
au plus vite à partenariat commercial
donald trump theresa may le nouveau duo
qui inquiète l'europe
le 45e président des états unis s'est
clairement félicité de break site
donald trump en est persuadé l'afflux
des migrants est responsable du break
site
l'europe serait un an
frimand dans les mains de l'allemagne et
d'autres états européens pourraient
suivre l'exemple britannique face aux
attaques contre l'europe et son
intégration pour l'instant les européens
ce arme légendaire flegme britannique
la meilleure façon de défendre l'europe
c'est un peu l'invitation que nous fûmes
se trompent ceux de rester unis de faire
bloc faire bloc
l'union européenne en est elle encore
capable les vingt-sept peuvent-ils sorti
renforcé de ce break site
adoubé par donald trump ou l'europe
risque t'elle d'imploser les mois qui
viennent nous en diront davantage
[Musique]
pour la trump break site est ce que
l'europe ait éclaté
richard corbett je pense pas parce que
qu'on reste de l'europe regarde le
catastrophe que va causer de break 6
pour le royaume uni
ils vont se dire on va pas faire la même
chose chez nous catastrophe pour le
royaume uni c'est à dire si les anglais
revenaient il y aurait pas eu il y
aurait pas de debre exit aujourd'hui
comme ça c'est très passé de
l'augmentation du coût de la vie
c'était un vote très serré et bon il ya
des gens qui veulent le président coûte
que coûte mais beaucoup ont voté pour le
proxy pour à condition que ça ne coûte
rien parce qu'on leur a promis on va
gagner de l'argent on va mettre ça dans
le système de santé
et maintenant qu'ils savent faire que
qu'il s'avère que le break 6 est une
affaire très coûteuse le royaume uni on
parle d'une baisse du pouvoir d'achat
reste du pouvoir d'un ou des prix de
certains produits de sacrés du à son
d'affiché 45% des britanniques retrait
pour le break site aujourd'hui oui à
l'envi vu les coûts énormes et les gens
commencent maintenant à percevoir sa
cette réponse et c'est tout à fait
légitime de ceux qui ont voté pour le
break section se basent leur dire c'est
pas pour ça que j'ai voté c'est pour ça
comment raconter
moi je veux le droit de réfléchir à
nouveau
nathalie griesbeck cia des risques et
candice location de robes jean marc
ayrault qui dit restons unis je trouve
qu'il est un peu candide par rapport à
la situation des états membres c'est pas
restons unis soyons consolidons devenons
unis et concrétisons 7
cette union qui est nécessaire et qui
est salutaire par rapport à ces deux
événements que vous avez mis en
parallèle l'installation de trump aux
états unis qui fait ami ami avec tout ce
qui donc sont pour éloigner le royaume
uni de l'union européenne
et puis madame et qui au moins a
clairement dit
au lieu de nous dire tout le temps
depuis des mois break 6 10 briques site
c'est-à-dire d'enfoncer des portes
ouvertes au mois elle a annoncé à
bréxent il dure moi je veux connaître
l'agenda le déclare le déclenchement de
l'article 50 les effets de la décision
de la cour sur la consultation
maintenant du parlement bien sûr le
référendum était consultatif mais la
position elle a été clair et ça ne prend
pas ce tour là du côté de ce qu'a dit
votre première ministre elle veut avoir
le beurre et l'argent du beurre elle
veut faire durer
alors je vous dis moi en tant
qu'européenne que ils ont pris des
positions qui sont à miami matin
monsieur tron donc nous défendons nous
défendons nous agissons jean quatremer
theresa may le discours de thérèse à
metz et à brac site dur c'est un peu on
veut être les maîtres chez nous c'est un
peu le même discours que donald trump ce
qui est ce qu'il faut voir c'est
qu'entre trump et theresa may c'est le
changement géopolitique majeur que
connaît le monde
pourquoi parce que depuis 1945 les
européens et le monde entier pouvait
compter sur leurs alliés anglo saxons
dire que c'est eux qui ont gagné la
seconde guerre mondiale comme ils ont
gagné la première guerre mondiale sans
eux
après la grande alors été perdus et la
seconde guerre mondiale aurait été perdu
aujourd'hui on parlerait tous allemands
sans les britanniques et sans les
américains
et là on a dit les britanniques qui
disent nous terminé on redevient à porte
avions plutôt rattachés aux états unis
et les américains qui disent eux
carrément on veut l'explosion de
l'europe ça sonne m'intéresse pas
copé tout l'europe qu'est ce que c'est
c'est un concurrent commerciale donc au
fond si elle disparaît c'est pas notre
problème jusqu'à présent le fait que
aujourd'hui ça le plan marshall après la
seconde guerre même si un changement
majeur où vivent 70 ans ou bascule d'un
monde à l'autre en 1945 sans à
l'amérique à l'europe n'aurait pas
n'aurait pas existé
l'europe à consolider la paix qui a été
imposé par les américains
heureusement mais aujourd'hui on essaie
laqué qui se désintéresse alors qu'est
ce que ça veut dire
jusqu'à présent les américains et les
britanniques assurer la sécurité du
vieux continent et on pouvait tout se
chamailler entre nous on était des
tribus gauloises donc au fond les
polonais pouvait acheter américain
il pouvait
euh s'engueuler avec les hongrois les
français pouvaient faire la tête aux
allemands en lisant je vais pas sérieux
sur la question la défense sécurité et
l'a brutalement
on a un grand frère les deux grands
frères qui disparaissent qui s'en vont
qui vont voir ailleurs et lors là on est
face à nos responsabilités
c'est ça qui est majeur alors risque
d'éclatement oui mais si on éclate on
disparaît c'est la fin de l'europe le
vieux continent disparaît de la face de
l'histoire et la légende quand même on a
ou va en france et on voit en allemagne
de l'histoire vous n'êtes pas
catastrophiste
c'est simple on l'a fait en 67 millions
d'habitants le reste du monde 7
milliards d'habitants
il ya eu quand même juste être sérieux
nous disparaîtrons divisée donc
aujourd'hui du temps du côté français
que du côté allemand on en a conscience
et je crois qu'effectivement le fait que
nous soyons isolés voire que nous ayons
des nouveaux ennemis à l'eau port va
nous obliger à un sursaut va nous
obliger à nous renforcer
donc au fond je me dis bon c'est
terrible parce que trump c'est
terrifiant mais teresa mais à côté elle
est sympathique troupes servant
terrifiant et d'avoir quelqu'un comme
trump peut peut-être nous aider à
surmonter nos divergences et enfin et à
surmonter surtout le nom français de
1954 à la communauté européenne de
défense qui a été tué l'idée d'une idée
d'une défense européenne
donc là peut-être qu'il va se passer des
choses les chars corbett le leader de la
gauche anglaise à double break site à
l'opposition c'est étonnant cette
position de jérémy encore been le patron
du labour
est-ce que trump une influence aussi les
gauches européennes
ah non le la gauche britannique et
n'aime pas du tout le tram ne s'en prend
d'ailleurs donc ce oui ça n'a rien à
voir
oui mais quand même on voit qu'en grande
bretagne aujourd'hui une partie de la
gauche au fond s'est fait à l'idée du
brésil voire au sein du parti traces de
votre parti travailliste soutient le
brésil veut dire qu'une des raisons pour
lesquelles leurs efforts demandés perd
10 parce que votre leader qui est un pas
mais certains des il faut quand même
accepter le résultat du référendum et
votre compagne et nuls
les travaillistes l'été
il aurait pu être meilleur à la vôtre je
parle de celle de corinne une phrase si
le royaume uni n'avait pas dû accueillir
tant de réfugiés il n'y aurait pas eu de
bréxent its et donald trump qui parle
alors c'est vrai c'est faux c'est notre
rubrique chaque paint préparé avec soin
par thomas millions le break site n'a
pas fini de faire parler de lui
donald trump est allé de son commentaire
dans une interview donnée au times pour
le président américain si le royaume uni
n'avait pas dû accueillir tant de
réfugiés il n'y aurait pas eu de vrai qu
site
alors même si l'on ne peut pas refaire
l'histoire voyons ce qu'il en est tout
d'abord combien de réfugiés
le royaume uni at il accueilli en 2015
il y a eu quarante mille demandes
d'asile enregistrées soit 75 % de plus
qu'en 2010 à l'échelle de l'union cette
hausse est loin d'être la plus forte
plus note 170 % en allemagne ou encore
plus 730% en italie au total en europe
les demandes d'asile ont augmenté de
500% entre 2010 et 2015 cette
augmentation est elle pour autant la
raison d'un vote en faveur du bric site
quand on regarde la situation ville par
ville
il semble bien que cette hausse de
l'immigration y compris immigration
européenne aurait effectivement
influencer les votes vers un vrai qu
site
comme l'a démontré des économistes là où
la population immigrée a augmenté de
plus de 200%
c'est le lierse il a toujours remporté à
quelques exceptions près les enquêtes
d'opinion confirme aussi que la question
semble avoir eu un poids non négligeable
dans l'isoloir le jour du scrutin un
sondage ipsos montrait que l'immigration
était le principal sujet de
préoccupation
au royaume uni un sentiment certainement
renforcée par la campagne des propres
excite le you keep de nigel farage en
tête qui a misé en grande partie sur cet
argument anti immigration
donc même s'il est impossible de le
prouver scientifiquement affirmée comme
la fed donald trump que sans crise
migratoire il n'y aurait pas eu de break
6 et bien c'est plausible à la plausible
sans crise migratoire il n'y aurait pas
eu de debreak site jean quatremer
il ya deux choses qui confrontera les
problèmes de l'immigration intra
européennes et l'émigration extra
européennes c'est vrai que la grande
bretagne n'a absolument pas reçu des
flots de réfugiés
c'est nous qui avons géré le problème
des britanniques on va penser à calais
c'est nous qui avons stoppé les vagues
migratoires en italie en grèce en
allemagne et en france
donc les britanniques ça de ce côté là
ils sont d'une mauvaise foi totale
cela étant c'est vrai que de voir les
scènes aux frontières de l'union
européenne a sans doute concouru à
augmenter la panique d'une partie des
électeurs britanniques
mais le grand problème même passé celui
de l'immigration intra européennes et
alors là quand même
les britanniques sont largement
responsables je vous rappelle qu'au
moment de l'élargissement
les français avaient demandé des
périodes de transition de quinze ans
avant d'accepter la libre circulation
des travailleurs polonais hongrois que
tony blair avec son arrogance
britannique typique avait expliqué que
les français vous et eux on était soit
disant des gens totalement égoïste qui
veulent accueillir nos frères de l'est
on a finalement obtenu 7 en cinq ans
plus deux ans de prolongation
les britanniques ont immédiatement lever
toutes les barrières au nom justement de
cette grande union européenne
et le résultat c'est que aujourd'hui il
se retrouve des millions de travailleurs
polonais et c'est vrai que quand vous
voyez dans certaines villes des
augmentations de 2 100 % du nombre
d'étrangers
c'est la paix ça montre à quel point ça
n'a pas été manager mais encore une fois
les britanniques ont été pris au piège
de leur idéologie totalement libérale
richard corbett ya eu panique chez les
britanniques au niveau d'immigration et
surtout ce sentiment était exploité par
opus from may tous ceux qui prônaient le
ils font la malle garay j'ai des
réfugiés et migrants économiques et de
la libre circulation des travailleurs en
europe et vous savez une chose la
plupart des immigrants au royaume uni
viennent de dehors de l'union européenne
de vie ça n'a rien à voir avec du sel
les règlements européens ont rien c'est
la loi britannique du gers a été
ministre de l'intérieur pendant des
années qui a dit il faut réduire
l'immigration elle a échoué complètement
même pour cette partie qu'elle contrôle
entièrement
ensuite il a dit oui mais c'est à cause
de l'europe que je ne peux rien faire
ce qui est faux ce qui est faux et c'est
ça qui a contribué à la partie turque
c'est donc ça veut dire unis vont les
afghans et pakistanais
c'est ça voulait dire l'afrique
bien sûr que ça a joué sur l'élection
mais ça n'est pas le seul facteur et ce
phénomène là on vient de voir à travers
la position trump il joue aussi dans les
états membres de l'union européenne qui
eux ont accueilli notamment ceux qui ont
accueilli aux frontières externes de
l'union européenne
ça signifie pour nous qu'on doit
rebondir qu'on doit travailler des
politiques européennes des 450 millions
que nous sommes aujourd'hui quand le
royaume uni sera sortie est à cet égard
moi j'aimerais bien que l'agenda ne soit
pas un agenda en caoutchouc et que le
déclenchement de l'article 50 se fasse
qu'on avance qu'on sorte de l'hypocrisie
et des fausses idées c'est pas vous que
j'attaque chers collègues puisque vous
étiez contre le break site
mais c'est nous que je défends nous
n'allons pas maintenant faire durer la
machine jusqu'à ce que vous a terrifié
nous devons rebondir nous devons
rebondir face aux propos de trump sur la
défense face au caractère terrifiant de
de ce qu'il raconte avec une inculture
majeur en expliquant que l'europe c'est
la paix c'est un concurrent commercial
je remplacerais à la botte de
l'allemagne et il oublie totalement ce
qu'a très bien expliqué jean quatremer à
l'instant sur les raisons de la paix en
europe
ils oublient qu selon les américains qui
sont venus et qui ont joué un rôle
majeur dans la seconde guerre mondiale
donc oui l'union soviétique sion vous
avez pris position maintenant moi comme
européenne française
je souhaite qu'on avance qu'on
rebondisse qu'on fasse de ce caractère
imprévisible et dangereux du monde vous
avez vu les renversements d'alliances
maintenant r2 one qui change de pied qui
est avec tout in pour les raisons que
l'on ne va pas expliquer ici alors que
ce n'était pas le cas
le bric site l'arrivée de trump qu'on
change de pied et qu on réaffirme nos
positions on se renforce pour justement
ne pas être juste un pour cent de la
population du monde mais un empire
continent un petit empire continent elle
au même moment les populistes européens
à se réclamer de donald trump a le front
national et ses alliés européens réunis
à coblence en allemagne ont cherché à
s'inscrire dans le sillage du nouveau
président américain on regarde et on
réagit juste après
[Musique]
coblence en allemagne
ici se déroule un contre sommet européen
le congrès des droites extrêmes et
populistes européennes des formations
d'extrême droite d'allemagne d'italie
d'autriche et de belgique ou des pays
bas
invité d'honneur marine le pen
l'occasion pour la patronne du front
national de prédire une révolte
électorale cette année en europe guerre
2002 chef de l'extrême droite
hollandaise est de la partie sa cible
les musulmans
les gens en ont assez de ces frontières
ouvertes et moi j'espère qu'il n'y aura
plus d'attaqués terroristes
mais j'ai peur qu'on en voit beaucoup
d'autres regardez ce qui se passe avec
les migrations massives et le déni du
problème de l'islamisation par les
pouvoirs publics
au même moment à coblence près de 5000
manifestants ils sont venus dire non à
une europe populiste et renfermée sur
elle même comme on le voit dans
plusieurs états européens les populistes
de droite sont déjà au gouvernement
c'est pourquoi nous devons nous lever et
faire clairement comprendre qu'elle ne
voulons pas que l'allemagne aille dans
cette direction
nous ne savons pas retourner dans les
nationalismes et trahir nos valeurs sous
l'oeil de mille policiers
beaucoup de jeunes et des pancartes en
allemand comme celle ci on peut lire
celui qui dort en démocratie peut se
réveiller d'un sous dictature
[Musique]
voilà celui qui dort démocratie peut se
réveiller dans une dictature nathalie
griesbeck
ben oui c'est le risque je constate 21
janvier c'est le jour de la mort du roi
louis saez c'est rigolo symboliquement
et surtout qu'il ya plus de manifestants
contre leurs positions de repli de
xénophobie et de racisme est aussi plus
de policiers que de tenant de ce
discours ça c'est pour l'environnement
peut-être sur le fond le fait que le
leader du front national accompagné de
ses amis qui existe un petit peu en
europe et qui savent justement sur les
difficultés et sur parfois la paralysie
des européens à se mettre d'accord sur
des vraies politiques européennes
je constate que ce rapprochement avec
trump et bien moi je m'en réjouis parce
que trump n'apparaît pas pour les
citoyens européens comme un modèle au
contraire chaque jour qui passe
annonce les civiliser le front national
vous pensez que moi en tous les cas je
pense que c'est intéressant et c'est à
suivre de très près et alors pas
justement à regarder avec un an pas en
agitant des mots et des épées de papier
en se mettant d'accord en rebondissant
comme l'a dit jean quatremer en agissant
alors y'a je suis pas candide il ya des
difficultés parce que jusqu'à présent
l'europe était sur certains points un
peu dans dans un monde de bisounours où
on regardait pas les disparités entre
l'ouverture en termes de droits de
douane on se laissait un petit peu moi
je veux qu'on se défende et qu'on se
batte et que on aboutisse à organiser
les choses
j'étais par exemple rapporteur sur les
garde-côtes gardes frontière là on agit
vite en six mois c'est fait aujourd'hui
mais mis un rapport sur le le début
d'activité qui date du 7 décembre
il faut qu'on avance qu'on se mette
d'accord qu'on s'unisse et que vous
annonciez aussi que l'on puisse
donner à l'europe une image force alors
que le groupe europe des nations et des
libertés qui réunit au parlement
européen le front national le fp aux
autrichiens la ligue du nord italienne
où le pvv néerlandais tous présents à
combler ans comme on l'a vu dans le
sujet c'est la plus petite formation au
sein de l'institution européenne au sein
du parlement européen avec seulement 40
députés
est ce que c'est la face émergée d'une
nouvelle europe comme le dit gerd enders
moi je dis d'abord il faut bien voir que
historiquement les antieuropéens les
europhobes les populistes je dirais que
tous les démagogues la série les
eurosceptiques wild et anti-européenne
les wallabies euros frais j'appelle ça
les europhobes c'est toujours été
compris entre 100 et 120 députés
il ya une grande vague en 1984 on a
oublié un fonds gardé un peu l'histoire
des chiffres donc on a l'impression
qu'il ya une vague qui en train de nous
submerger
c'est pas le cas en plus je dirais que
je suis d'accord avec ta télé grise mais
quand elle dit que l'élection de trains
et même le brésil je rajouterais est une
mauvaise surprise pour nos amis
démagogique des parties démagogues
pourquoi pas ce que l'on va voir enfin
en réel leur solution donc theresa may
va quitter l'union européenne et là on
va voir économiquement les conséquences
donc l'aller les citoyens français
italiens vont dire ouh là ça posait
vraiment des problèmes parce qu'il va y
avoir des problèmes
faut pas se le cacher tout le monde on
est d'accord le brésil n'a pas encore eu
lieu quand il aura une audience avec ça
va vraiment être terrible pour les
britanniques et trump parce que trump
met en place les solutions que propose
marine le pen le mur interdirait les
musées aux musulmans de venir aux états
unis la fermeture reste du monde
et là on va voir en grandeur réelle
l'application des solutions des partis
fascistes ou néofasciste là à mon avis
ça va calmer quelques ardeurs donc moi
je dirais que c'est en dommages pour les
britanniques est dommage pour les
américains surtout dus pour l'équilibré
du monde
mais n'empêche que cette leçon grandeur
nature adapté de faire réfléchir un
certain nombre de gens je ne désespère
pas de l'intelligence concitoyens notre
collègue
des rides ils ont voté mais maintenant
qu'il voit les effets que hsbc bas
partie un collège a pas justement juste
en voyant qu'il faut un espace justement
les échéances électorales c'est
exactement ce midi notre collègue
il dit maintenant qu on voit la réalité
ah bah on changerait d'avis alors ça
c'est plus possible mais a laissé parler
de l'édition électorale en allemagne en
france et aux pays-bas vont être
cruciales cette année pour l'europe
on parle d'un exit une sortie des pays
bas l'union européenne sait si c'est
possible
à mon avis c'est très peu probable mais
c'est ça que je veux monsieur windows et
l'extrême droite bien sûr je les voir
ensemble comme ça il ya quand même un
président hugh type où les médias
donnent l'eau à izon va pas durer une
chose en commun
ces gens là ils haïssent des étrangers
donc il faillit mutuellement
mais pour la presse il vit pendant prés
new type le patin de l'état n'y vois je
re après jour que qu'ils sont divisés
qu'il se conteste y occuper dans lé dans
le volume était dans le lot par lot ils
étaient les anti européens où les héros
c'est pour des raisons tactiques qu'il
ne voulait pas être un suspense à la fin
d'un manille sont ils sont très proches
madoff arraché marine le pen ce sont de
grands amis oui c'est tout à fait exact
quand on voit les parties les partis
europhobes néo fasciste et autres
ensembles c'est très drôle parce que de
fait il n'arrive pas à travailler
ensemble
la fameuse europe des nations qu'il
souhaite en fait c'est l'europe des
confrontations
parce qu'ils n'aiment pas les étrangers
alors il déteste les musulmans ça c'est
le maximum
ensuite mais il n'aime pas les autres
étrangers parce que l'étranger c'est
celui qui cause des problèmes et je
crois que c'est quelque chose et quand
on les voit dans les groupes et moi je
les observe depuis longtemps parlement
européen les groupes d'extrême droite
pour jamais fonctionné parce que woods à
maman effectivement il y en a un qui se
prend pour étendre comme étant la race
supérieure par rapport aux voisins et ça
explose à chaque fois ça a explosé
donc voilà il dit ils s'aiment pas il y
aurait si l'europe disparaît antony
costes nous dire retour à l'europe
d'avant guerre ça c'est clair quand on
les voit crayon cette unité et cette
union pour dans ce monde dangereux
avec de la défense avec une monnaie
unique qui soit forte
avec pourquoi pas à l'europe des cercles
moi ça fait des années que j'explique
que comme on est quand même nombreux
feux travaillons dans la zone euro avec
les autres états membres et avec des
politiques européennes revoyant de fond
en comble la politique migratoire en
tenant compte des menaces extrêmement
fortes qui pèsent sur la planète et bien
ce sera le mot de la fin merci à vous
trois d'avoir accepté notre invitation
et merci à vous de nous avoir suivis
bonne suite des programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires baba et
[Musique]